your wild card race the reds after the
padres won yesterday find themselves on
the outside looking in right now just a
half game back
of the padres the phillies two and a
half games back the cardinals three
games back the man who will be facing
all those right-handed hitters is justin
steele and he'll throw a four-seamer at
94 miles an hour sliders of out pitch
for him
a sinker curveball
and occasionally a change-up cowboy nick
castellanos kills his former club the
cubs if you can be relaxed
you can be an awfully good hitter
and that's a fair ball castellanos
connects takes a turn he'll challenge
for two throw to second base not in time
there is such a fine line between
being relaxed and
trying to get your mind to a point where
you're not so worried about results and
then you also have to be able to execute
as castianos does here hitting just over
180.
he swings and misses a steal carves him
up and pitches around a two out double
well done by justin steele i think when
you're looking at sonny greg last seven
starts he's 5-0 he looks like the normal
sunny gray and
what better time to to have a big guy
like sunny gray in your rotation really
starting to find it as you head into the
last
three four starts of september and he
has found it
on the ground to first and that one just
eats up as drupal cabrero
and a leadoff man is on base
it was hit pretty hard 100.3 miles an
hour
the exit velo
did hard base hit left field what else
is new
he just keeps on hitting ian happ last
year
was arguably the top offensive player on
the team led him in ops led at homers
drills that one left center field
towards the gap going back and it's gone
it just snuck down into the basket in
left center field he and half will touch
them all the 2-2 pitch and it is strike
3 call right over the inside corner and
comes the payoff pitch
right on the inside corner strike 3 call
good pitch from sonny gray he
bounces back after surrendering a
three-run home run to retire the final
three batters
steel starts the second inning with a
cushioned patch
swinging a miss right three three
pitches three swings three misses
leading off the cubs second inning now
he swings the 1-0 pops one up foul
territory beyond first as grubel cabrera
over there he makes the catch and then
falls over the sidewall into the net
he catches himself though into the net
and that is the first out of the second
inning strike three called right over
the inside corner dow contra he doesn't
like it but he is back to the dugout bat
in hand third strikeout victim of sonny
gray today cubs lead three nothing as we
go to the top of the third swing and a
missed strike three fastball steal back
to work
and he went too far that's a strikeout
and that's four for justin steele one of
the reasons why ortega is hit for a high
average he doesn't hit it on the ground
very often so that he doesn't pay that
shift penalty like so many guys do
oh that beautifully runs that fast
now he gets a rematch with ian however
19 home runs first fish swinging hits at
a high
fly ball into right field the wind will
keep that in and it is a quick inning
for sonny gray here in the third he
threw 24 pitches in that three run first
seven pitches in the second inning six
in the third inning and their strike
three and wisdom saying the slider
before was in the same spot
it was he's right wisdom is right since
the home run by hap in the first the
cubs have not had a base runner against
gray
and that's drilled past cabrera down the
line and towards the right field corner
jason racing for second he's around
second on his way to third and hayward
will slide in with a triple fun to watch
him run the bases he really cuts the
corners
tightly
great technique and again we've seen
more good swings from jason hayward more
of those getting those arm arms extended
and hitting the ball hard in the air
pull side duffy waving the bat out over
the plate
strike three call
gray dancing lower third outer edge
sonny gray saw the first three reach all
scored on a homer by ian happ since then
13 men faced one has reached a hayward
triple six strikeouts
all looking for their swing and missed
seven k's for grin and again that pitch
is a strike no matter what swing and a
miss eight strikeouts for sonny gray as
he got steal to go after the high
fastball last timeout
five scoreless innings one hit so far
today
five scoreless innings
three hits to
my aquino
and walk to stevenson reds get their
lead off man on you know castillanos is
probably the poster boy for what the
attitude should be which is win every
at-bat here's a drive into the
right-field corner that's going to be an
extra base set for castellanos chasing
it down as hayward racing to third
safely stevenson on a two-base hit by
castillanos
load the bases and a limp for suarez
there is no doubt
cabrera trying to pull the ball here or
looking for the ball middle end
way in it got it
and that's a run the reds on the board
after back-to-back bruises
and stevenson crosses bases still loaded
nobody out cody hoyer is on his
inherited runner numbers are excellent
trying to get the ball on the ground
ball bounces away appeal says no goal
break for home tag
safe slide castellanos you can see him
go down for the ball it kicked right off
the
thumb portion of his mitt because the
breaking ball had such velocity
contreras actually had a play at the
plate he just thought it was do or die
and throwing the ball back towards the
mound rather than on the plate is what
cost him there max schrock is going to
hit here for delino de payoff
lines it to left down the line that'll
get down and cut off in the corner by
half but suarez will score
cabrera around to third and shrug into
second with a pinch hit rbi double to
tie the game at three michael lorenzo
is on out of the bullpen
reevos
that's that hard and through the right
side base hit that's a really good at
bat from alfonso rivas presenting the
go-ahead run it could be huge well here
he goes that one squirts away from
stevenson and down to second goes rebas
schwendell in this one one for three
[Applause]
base hit right field reevos around third
on his way to the plate and he will
score
frank the tank has done it again
that looked intentional too really
worked hard to get on top of that pitch
and punch it into right field
motto does not have the numbers
that we have seen in the past for him
against left-handed pitching
mono clubs into center caught on the
slide
reds lose by a run they have dropped
seven of nine
nine of 13. the cubs have won seven
straight